hello and welcome to this video playing
black against
international master aero limit do we
know what that is
from ukraine okay
so
let's see okay he
transposes to an english symmetrical
black has multiple options i've played
bishop f5 as well
but i i always feel like i play that
bishop f5 line but i really don't
understand what's going on so
maybe go for something else here
yeah white is trying to expand a bit on
the queen side
i'm just completing this typical setup
with
g6 b6 and so on it's a
very solid setup for black
and oftentimes um
it gives fairly good equality
queen d7 rook c8 things like that are
coming next
okay this is this is an ambitious way to
play with deform
okay maybe he
takes with the knight i didn't okay he
doesn't take
the knight
i saw that here c5 runs into b takes
which is just fine for black
and therefore i thought i should be okay
here
oh okay
i mean runs into is a bit strong i just
felt that this should be fine i have
this like queen here
knight here attack the pawn
um queen a5 there's
bishop d2 probably
knight f5 is also a reasonable choice
but this queen a4 which is annoying
but queen a5 bishop d2 is not helping so
i'm going to do this anyway queen a4
then queen c8 it's not
a problem i feel
yeah okay it just covers everything
this makes this move a little bit more
attractive as bishop d2 would be
just a weird time loss
and i can maybe just take stuff on
defaults possible
yeah this kind of situation i had in
mind when i thought that this
c5 push wasn't so dangerous
i thought this this must be fine
okay um the queen is covered so
there is no trickery here
sometimes there are tricks with
discovered
attacks
[Music]
okay now i really don't
want him to take
so i'm going to take here f takes is not
um absolutely ideal either
or for white
okay i can
yeah maybe i'm just materialistic take a
pawn
it doesn't want to give me a pawn
okay
the i mean the ending is certainly okay
but
wondering about e5 at the right moment
in this position
i can also play queen a4
yeah why not actually
try to be more active
so this one
and then get get on the b
file the bishop on g7 needs more
scope i can try e5
attacking that pawn that would be
generally useful but i have to be
cautious because
it takes yeah here
i thought just rook b7
as a simple solution this is also
interesting
[Music]
not a perfect move really
[Music]
need to get rid of that that night it's
really
a bit of a pain
g5 queen moves
i would have liked to have more time but
it just
had to make this decision now
ah this this endings are tricky
he gets this always ah
no i should never be worse in this
ending and i probably am
i know
it's freaking ridiculous the ending at
the very start it's just much better
for black and i managed to totally
misplay this
this stuff wow
yeah come on this is just awful
like he went into it just a terrible
ending and
i did not play this right i mean maybe
okay terrible it's not terrible it's
just it's just better for black
like losing it is awful like this
and i can simply take on d4 oh shoot
i mean e5 is also obviously good but
i can take here and that makes the thing
is this is so easy now to play i just
i mean the two knights are just
ridiculous here
and i have the easy play with the pawns
just push everything forward
ah that makes no sense at all okay e5 is
also good yeah
i mean but i just totally miss play this
knight a5 so d4
wow i thought d4 he has e4
i can simply take that pawn i'm such a
[ __ ]
i can simply take that and play king d5
and then of course this is just weak and
yeah this is easy now because that is
just a weak born
yeah that can be probably round up
somehow
like bishop back knight here or so and
then you get that pawn
i i completely i completely did not see
that after e4 i can just take
that's that's ridiculous knight a5 was
kind of a panic he moved because
i thought he he gets here and then i
don't really know what to do next yeah
and well he did that and
i take take
and now just a little bit knight c4 i
mean
this is just awful i mean his move is
also awful of course but
in knight a5 i had just three seconds
this is
just winning the pawn right
and that was just unspeakably awful this
ending
and even here h5 is still good i had no
time
yeah but you can still play better right
i'm just not doing this right
yeah i should never lose that i mean
besides the fact that
the the middle game was just better for
black as well
wouldn't even be surprised if i have
some kind of a win there somewhere
it's just a game that i had absolutely
no business
losing ever like i hear knight takes d4
is resigned
yeah he cannot take because i just go
back here right
yeah yeah it was
it was it was really difficult to lose
that game and
quincy two wins then wins the night and
so on
come on i shouldn't even look further i
just like missed everything yeah
i really missed everything here okay
thanks for watching